Donald Trump took time out of his busy
schedule a tweeting on the crapper to
take over the one place even more
batshit crazy than him Japanese
wrestling that's definitely him I own
DDT pro wrestling just unveiled our new
leader
Donald Trump when they say evolved out
of a regular Japanese wrestler quote
like a Pokemon and judging by this
picture I'm assuming it was Bulbasaur
this felt good you guys still playing
this Trump with Trump wasted no time
establishing his policies on gay rights
by announcing a quote anal explosion
death match between the world's
strongest gay wrestler and the world's
strongest penis fighter and unlike some
Donald Trump's I could name this one
follow through on its promises
[Applause]
under Trump care that's a prostate exam
okay is it done it also look like this
truck is going I've driven into the
pardon me I'll just be backing out what
are some other Japanese wrestling
matches trumple order right tiny some
wrestling yes fine
Stephanie slam them by the all
right boy very good very good
that's for sure father-daughter mud
wrestling yeah I mean the mud doctrinal
you know the month after oh we could
have it you cannot have it